في تركيا وسوريا كما نشاهد في الخبر
العاجل الى اكثر من ثمانيه الاف900 قتيل
في تركيا وحدها مشاهدينا تم تسجيله سته
الاف ومئتين واربعه وثلاثين قتيلا واكثر
من 37 الف جريح وذلك وفق اداره الكوارث
التركيه التي اضافت ان اكثر من 79 الف شخص
يشاركون في جهود الانقاذ عداد القتلى
مشاهدينا لا يتوقف اذا مع بطء عمليه
الانقاذ لصعوبتها وكبر المساحه التي
اصابها الزلزال فضلا عن الظروف الجويه
الصعبه في ولايه هاتاي التركيه المنكوبه
استيقظ السكان هذا الصباح على هزه ارضيه
بقوه اربع درجات ضربت سواحل الولايه اداره
الكوارث التركيه قدرت ان قطره زلزال وصل
الى دائره تفوق مساحتها 100 كلم مربع
وبعد ان اعلن رئيس التركي امس حاله
الطوارئ صدر اليوم في الجريده الرسميه
التركيه قرار سريان حاله الطوارئ لمده
ثلاثه اشهر في المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال
في تركيا الولايات العشر المعنيه مشاهدينا
هي اضنه واديامان
مرعش وكيليسا وملاطيه وعثمانيه
في هذه المدينه مشاهدينا نعني هاتاي تمكنت
الفرق المختصه من انقاذ اطفال كانوا
عالقين تحت انقاض احد الابنيه